hi everyone
this is professor m does science and
today i want to talk about changing
basis
in another one of our videos on rigorous
quantum mechanics when we do
calculations in quantum mechanics we
have to write states and operators in a
particular basis or representation
this means that the very first step in
any quantum mechanical calculation
is to choose a good basis that will make
the maths as easy as possible in this
process
being able to change from one basis to
another is essential and that's what
we'll look at today so without further
ado
let's go when we perform calculations in
quantum mechanics we invariably write
states and operators in a specific
representation
you can find all the details in the
video and representations which i link
in the description
but as a reminder a representation is a
choice of orthonormal bases
in state space in which we write cats
brass and operators
to see this in more detail consider a
collection of cats u
that are mutually orthonormal this gets
you from a basis if we can write
any ket psi in our state space in a
unique expansion in terms of these u
and we also know that in such an
expansion the c coefficients are given
by the bracket
between u and psi these c coefficients
are called the representation of psi
in the u basis as we also discussed in
the vidian representations
what we're doing here is analogous to
what we do when we work with the
familiar euclidean 3d vectors
we typically consider an abstract vector
r but when we want to do calculations we
have to write it down in terms of a
basis
for example in terms of the cartesian x
y z bases vectors
the expansion coefficients are given by
the scalar products between the basis
vectors and the vector r
bases work in analogous manner in both
vector spaces
the c coefficients are given by the
scalar product between the bases cat u
and the state psi of the system
and the expansion coefficient of the
euclidean 3d vector are also given by
the corresponding scalar products
in the video and representations we also
learned that we can write down brass in
a particular basis like this
where now the expansion coefficients are
the conjugates of the ket expansion
coefficients
and we can write down operators in a
particular basis like this
where the expansion coefficients called
matrix elements are given by this
in principle we can solve a quantum
problem using cats bras and operators
written in
any basis however the maths can be
widely different
depending on which bases we choose this
is the same that happens when we work
with euclidean vectors
for example if we have a problem with
spherical symmetry we could use a
cartesian basis to solve it but the mass
would be lengthy and cumbersome
if instead we use a spherical basis then
the math becomes simple and transparent
in the same spirit one of the most
important steps when solving a problem
in quantum mechanics
is to choose a good basis before we
start to do this
it is obvious that it will be very
important to be able to change from one
basis to another
and this is precisely what we'll explore
in this video
the central question in this video is
how do we go from one representation u
to a different representation v let's
start with cats
first we write out a ket psi in the u
basis
and the expansion coefficients just like
we had earlier are given by the bracket
between the u bases
and the state psi we can also write the
same state psi
in the v basis and in this case i call
the expansion coefficients d
which in turn are given by the bracket
between the corresponding basis state v
and the state psi changing bases of
representation essentially means that
given the c coefficients
which are the representation of psi in
the u basis how do we find the d
coefficients which are the
representation of psi in the v basis
to answer this question we start by
writing dj as the bracket between vj and
psi
then we insert the identity in the
middle and we now get to the critical
step of the derivation
we insert the resolution of the identity
in the u basis
like this after this we can move this
sum to the beginning
and we end up with sum over i of the
bracket between v j
and ui times the bracket between ui and
psi
this first term is the bracket between
vj and ui which like any other bracket
is a scalar
and we call it sji the second term is
the bracket between ui and psi
which we recognize as ci we can then
simplify the expression using these
definitions
and we get this what is this telling us
what we can see is that given the ci we
can find the dj by simply calculating
these numbers
sji these sji are given by this bracket
so what this means is that if we go from
one representation to another
all we have to do is to calculate the
overlaps between the corresponding basis
states
the collection of scalars sji are called
the overlap matrix
remembering the video on the matrix
formulation of quantum mechanics we can
see straight away that we can write this
expression
as column vector d equal to a matrix
with entries sji
multiplying the column vector c hence
the name
overlap matrix for s
now that we have established that we can
go from a basis u to a different basis v
by calculating the overlap matrix sji we
can ask the opposite question
how do we go from the basis v to the
basis u
the proof follows the exact same
procedure we just used in the previous
slide
and the answer is that c i equals the
sum over j of the bracket
u i v j times d j we can also write it
in terms of the overlap matrix because
using conjugation
uivj is equal to vj ui star
which is equal to sji star so what does
this mean
we can go from u to v by calculating the
overlapped matrix between the two bases
as shown up here
and we can go from v to u by calculating
the conjugate of the overlap matrix
as shown here we can summarize these
results by stating that we can go in any
direction between the u
and the v basis by simply calculating
the overlaps between the two sets of
basis states
and then we either use the overlaps
directly or their conjugates
the corresponding expressions for bras
are now easy to obtain we can either
repeat the same exercise we have just
done for cats
or we can directly transform the
expressions for the cats to the dual
space
either way i leave it to you as an
exercise
now that we know how to transform the
representation of states from one basis
u to another basis v and vice versa
the next question is how do we transform
the representation of operators
between bases we know that operators are
represented by the corresponding matrix
elements
so we start by writing the matrix
element of operator a in the u basis
and we also write the matrix element of
the same operator a
in the v basis we can eventually use the
same letter as the operator for the
matrix elements
in this case a so i have added these
superscripts u
here and v here to keep track of which
bases we're writing the operator in
the transformation question for
operators becomes given the
a i k in the u basis how do i find the
ajl in the v basis
the answer is in fact very similar to
the one we provided for the
transformation of cuts
we start by writing the matrix element
ajl
in the v basis we then insert
two identity operators and now we come
again to the crucial step of the
derivation
we resolve both identities in the u
basis
we now move both sums to the beginning
and we get sum over i
k of the bracket between v j u i
then the matrix element of a in the u
basis
and then the bracket u k v l
remembering the definition of the
overlap matrix we recognize this term
as the overlap matrix s j i and this
term as the complex conjugate of the
overlap matrix
s l k this term here in the middle is
the matrix element a
in the u basis and putting all of this
together we end up with sum over i
k of s j i a i k in the u basis
s l k star so what does this mean
given the representation of the a
operator in the u basis
we can find the corresponding
representation in the v basis by
calculating the overlapped matrices
sji and slk star
we can again use a similar procedure to
prove the opposite relation
and the final answer is this
putting everything together we have
found that transforming from one basis u
to another basis v requires the
calculation of the overlap matrix
sji between the two bases once we have
this overlap matrix we can use it to
transform states from the u basis to the
v
basis or we can use its conjugate
transform state in the reverse order
from the v basis to the u basis
similarly we use the overlapped matrix
and its conjugates to transform
operators
from u to v or from v to u
the ability to change from one basis to
another is central in quantum mechanics
because choosing a good basis can
greatly simplify the maths
for a concrete example of changing bases
take a look at the video on
wavefunctions
in that video we look at changing from
the position to the momentum basis we
use the ideas we've learned today and we
find that the position and momentum
representations
are related by a fourier transform as
always if you liked the video or like
send me suggestions for future videos
please subscribe